aquí muchas gracias
aquí para que tengas muchas gracias
me alegra mucho estar de vuelta
[Aplausos]
es bueno estar casi que en casa
justo al final del pasillo bueno muchas
gracias a todos
señora vicepresidenta
ningún presidente de las llamas ha dicho
esas palabras desde este punto el
presidente lo había hecho hasta ahora y
ya era hora
[Aplausos]
la primera dama
y su esposo
en el segundo caballero
pues
miembros del congreso de los eeuu
miembro del gabinete distinguidos
invitados compañeros estadounidenses
aunque la cita en la noche es familiar
esta reunión es solamente un poco
diferente es un recordatorio de las
épocas ordinarias que estamos viviendo a
lo largo de nuestra historia los
presidentes han venido a esta cámara a
hablarle al congreso a la nación y al
mundo a declarar guerra celebrar la paz
a anunciar nuevos planes nuevas
posibilidades
esta noche vengo a hablarles de la
crisis y de las oportunidades de la
reconstrucción de nuestra nación de la
revitalización de nuestra democracia y
de un futuro victorioso para los
estadounidenses estoy aquí esta noche
apenas a un día de los 100 días de mi
administración es 100 días
en los cuales juré con la biblia frente
a la nación todo lo hicimos y estábamos
en crisis la peor pandemia del siglo la
peor crisis económica desde la gran
depresión el peor ataque sobre nuestra
democracia desde la guerra civil ahora
después de nada más 100 días puede
reportarle a la nación que eeuu está
está de nuevo en camino
[Aplausos]
el paso de la crisis a la oportunidad
los retrocesos bueno todos conocemos que
la vida puede golpearnos pero en eeuu
jamás nunca jamás nos quedamos rendidos
eeuu siempre se levanta y hoy eso es lo
que estamos haciendo
eeuu está levantándose de nuevo
eligiendo la esperanza sobre el miedo la
verdad sobre las mentiras y la luz sobre
la oscuridad después de cien días de
rescate de renovación eeuu está de nuevo
lista para un despegue mi perspectiva
estamos trabajando de nuevo luchando
soñando de nuevo descubriendo y
liderando el mundo una vez más nos hemos
mostrado uno a otro y al mundo que no
hay una rendición en eeuu de como
rendirse en eeuu hace 100 días en la
casa de eeuu el hogar eeuu estaba en
llamas y tuvimos que actuar gracias al
liderazgo extraordinarios
p los hijos del líder de la mayoría
summers y más allá del respaldo del
pueblo estadounidense sea independiente
demócratas o republicanos lo logramos
juntos pasamos un plan de rescate
estadounidense el más consecuente en la
historia estadounidense ya estamos
viendo los resultados
ya estamos viendo estos resultados
después de haber prometido que
tendríamos 100 millones de vacunas en
los brazos de las personas
estadounidenses en ciencias hemos dado
más de 220 millones de vacunas para el
joven en esos 100 días gracias a la
ayuda de todos ustedes
como sylvain
estamos asegurando que con su ayuda con
la ayuda de todos estamos llevando todos
los recursos federales posibles vemos yo
acuerdas a 40 mil farmacias ya más de
700 centros comunitarios donde los más
pobres pueden pueden llegar a la vacuna
hemos establecido centros de vacuna
hemos desarrollado unidades móviles para
llegar al corazón de las comunidades y
hoy
el 90% de estadounidenses viven a menos
de 5 millas de un sitio de vacunas todos
y por encima de los 65 años todos
pueden ser vacunados justo en este
momento inmediatamente vayan a vacunarse
estadounidenses vayan a recibir la
vacuna están disponibles
y ustedes pueden recibir la hora
[Aplausos]
la mañana del 20 de enero menos de la
mitad de gente mayor estaba vacunada
cien años cien días después 70% de las
personas por encima a los 65 años de
edad están protegidas completamente
protegidas las muertes de los adultos
mayores están decreciendo en un 80 por
ciento desde enero 80% gracias a ustedes
en más de la mitad de todos los adultos
en eeuu ha recibido al menos una vacuna
un centro de vacunación masivo en
glendale arizona en ese centro le
pregunté a una enfermera cómo es esto
ella me miró y dijo es como si cada
vacuna esta fuera una dosis de esperanza
esa fue la frase una dosis de esperanza
una dosis de esperanza para un educador
en la florida
y cuyos hijos tienen enferma estaba
preocupado por llevar enfermedades a su
hogar dijo que se había vacunado en un
gran en un sitio grande en su en su auto
se sentó y aprender a vacunar empezó a
llorar a llorar de dicha a llorar de
alivio los padres están viendo sonrisas
en sus hijos porque pueden volver a las
escuelas porque sus profesores
conductores fueron vacunados los abuelos
lanzan abrazos de sus nietos
esos viviendo de nuevo en vez de
presionarse sus bebés humanos a través
de un vidrio una ventana despidiéndose
esto es todo estas cosas significan todo
para nosotros
miren todavía ustedes todos lo saben lo
sabe mejor que cualquier grupo de
estadounidenses hay mucho trabajo por
hacer para vencer este virus no podemos
bajar la guardia no hay pero hoy
y yo puedo decir que por ustedes por su
trabajo el pueblo estadounidense está
nuestro progreso en estos últimos 100
días en contra de la peor pandemia la
historia ha sido uno de los mayores
logros logísticos logros logísticos que
este país ha visto que más hemos hecho
en estos cien días mantuvimos nuestro
compromiso demócratas y republicanos
de enviar un rescate de 1400 dólares a
85 por ciento de hogares estadounidenses
ya hemos enviado más de 160 millones de
cheques esto está marcando una
diferencia y todos ustedes lo saben
cuando vuelven a casa para muchas
personas está marcando toda la
diferencia del mundo a una madre soltera
en texas que me escribió me dijo que no
podía trabajar pero este cheque de
alivio él me puso comida en sus mesas
le arrolló a ella ya su hijo ser sacado
de su apartamento una abuela en virginia
me escribió me dijo que llevó a su nieta
inmediatamente al doctor al oftalmólogo
algo que había pospuesto por meses
porque no tenía el dinero son imágenes
definitivas al menos desde mi
perspectiva de lo que ha sido esta
crisis hay carros que están haciendo
filas caros están haciendo filas de
millas
y no es gente que está bueno que son
carros no son carros baratos son carros
buenos que están haciendo filas
esperando que les entreguen una caja de
comidas no sé ustedes pero nunca pensé
que fuera a ver eso en eeuu y todo esto
no es culpa de ellos no
no es culpa de ninguna de esas personas
ellos no tienen por qué estar en esta
posición
por eso es que este plan de rescate
están llevando asistencia nutricional y
comida a millones de estadounidenses que
están enfrentando el hambre y ya esto ha
bajado también estamos dando asistencia
para la renta ustedes todos lo saben
pero quiero asegurarme que el pueblo
estadounidense lo sepa estamos
impidiendo que la gente sea expulsada de
sus hogares estamos dando préstamos a
los pequeños negocios para que puedan
reabrir y mantener a sus empleados
trabajando durante estos 100 días
800 mil estadounidenses más se unieron
al acta de salud 800 mil estadounidenses
en ese período estamos haciendo una de
las mayores inversiones únicas en la
mejoría de la salud para los veteranos
en versiones críticas para enfrentar esa
crisis de los opiáceos e incluso más
importantes gracias al plan de rescate
estadounidense estamos en camino
a recortar la pobreza infantil a la
mitad de este año
estamos en proceso durante este proceso
de la economía creo más de 1.300.000
trabajos nuevos en 100 días más trabajos
más trabajos en los primeros 100 días
que cualquier otro presidente en estos
registros también tenemos un mundo
fornet un fondo monetario
el fondo más el fondo meta internacional
de estimado que nuestra economía va a
crecer más de 6% este año ese sería el
ritmo más rápido de crecimiento
económico en más de cuatro décadas para
este país a eeuu se está moviendo hacia
adelante pero no podemos detenernos
ahora estamos compitiendo con china y
con otros países para ganar este siglo
21 el gran punto de inflexión en la
historia tenemos que hacer más que con
reconstruir tenemos que reconstruir los
mejor tenemos que competir tenemos que
hacerlo con más fortaleza que antes a lo
largo de nuestra historia
la inversión pública y la inversión en
infraestructura ha transformado
literalmente a eeuu nuestras actitudes
tanto como nuestras oportunidades la vía
férrea transcontinental las autopistas
interestatales unen dos océanos y nos
trajeron a una nueva era de progreso a
los eeuu de américa
la educación universal el apoyo
universitario abrió las puertas de
oportunidades los logros científicos de
ahora la lugar estamos en marte
descubriendo vacunas tenemos internet y
hay muchas muchas cosas más
estas son inversiones
pero juntos como un solo país
inversiones que solamente el gobierno
podía hacer una y otra vez nos han
llevado hacia el futuro por eso es que
propongo el plan de trabajo
estadounidense una inversión
generacional en eeuu
esta es este es el mayor plan laboral
desde la segunda guerra mundial
crea trabajos mejora nuestra
infraestructura de transporte y crea
trabajo modernizar nuestras vías puentes
autopistas esos trabajos que construyen
puertos aeropuertos autos
es el agua es la limpieza del agua y hoy
más de 10 millones de hogares de eeuu y
más de 400.000 escuelas y centros de
cuidado infantil tienen cañerías con
hongos es un gran peligro la salud de
nuestros niños
el plan de trabajo estadounidense crea
trabajos y reemplaza 100%
de estas cañerías llenas de hongos para
que cada estadounidense pueda tomar agua
limpia
en el proceso crearemos miles y miles de
trabajos bien pagos
se crea trabajos conectando a cada
estadounidense con un internet de alta
velocidad incluyendo un 35 por ciento de
eeuu rural que todavía no lo tiene esto
va a ayudar a nuestros niños ya que
nuestros negocios tengan éxito en la
economía del siglo 21 les pregunto
ustedes le pido a la vicepresidenta que
lidere este esfuerzo por favor porque sé
que ella lo logrará
y esto crea trabajos es construir una
red de energía moderna la actual es
vulnerable a los hackeos a los errores
catastróficos a las tormentas y esto
generaría resultados trágicos como ya
hemos visto en texas y en otros sitios
con las tormentas el plan laboral de
eeuu que le dará trabajos y creará
líneas de transmisión millas de líneas
para construir una red resiliente y
fuerte y resistente y podemos hacerlo
miren
el plan laboral de eeuu ayudará a
millones de personas volver a su empleo
y volver a sus carreras
dos millones de mujeres
han abandonado su empleo durante esta
pandemia 2 millones y es frecuentemente
porque no recibe la asistencia que
necesitan para cuidar a sus hijos
a un padre mayor de edad que necesita
ayuda
800.000 familias están en la lista de
espera de medicare para recibir atención
en el hogar para su padre de edad o su
ser amado con discapacidad si usted cree
que no es importante revise en su propio
distrito demócrata republicano demócrata
republicano cualquier votante su gran
preocupación tanto como sus hijos es
encargarse de un ser querido mayor de
edad que no puede ser dejado solo
mary kate lo contemplo pero este plan va
a ayudar a estas familias y creará
trabajos para los cuidadores con mejores
salarios y mejores beneficios para
seguir para seguir con este ciclo de
crecimiento por mucho tiempo no hemos
usado la palabra más importante cuando
se trata de enfrentar la crisis
climática empleos empleos
empleos
para mí cuando pienso el cambio
climático pienso en empleos el plan de
empleos todavía se pondrá a los
ingenieros a los constructores a creer a
crear edificaciones más eficientes que
trabajan en eléctricas
los trabajadores están haciendo más de
500 mil estaciones eléctricas en
nuestras autopistas para que podamos
apropiarnos del mercado de los carros
eléctricos los granjeros y los granjeros
que planean cubrir sus cultivos para
bajar su huella de carbono y recibir
dinero por ello miren
cuando lo pensamos realmente no hay
razones por las cuales
estos molinos de energía eólica no
pueden ser construidos en estados unidos
sino en beijing no hay ninguna razón
miren damas y caballeros
no hay ninguna razón por la cual eeuu a
los trabajadores estadounidenses no
pueda liderar el mundo
en la producción de vehículos eléctricos
y baterías no hay ninguna razón tenemos
las capacidades
tenemos a la gente mejor entrenada del
mundo el plan estadounidense empleos va
a crear millones de trabajos bien pagos
trabajos con los que los estadounidenses
puedan criar a su familia como muy padre
alguno va es dijo
todas las inversiones de este plan serán
guiados por un principio compre
estadounidense compre estadounidense
[Aplausos]
y voy a hablar esto sin ningún tipo de
paréntesis
[Aplausos]
esto no viola ningún tratado comercial y
ha sido la ley desde los años 30 comprar
estadounidense los impuestos
estadounidenses van a ser usados para
confiar para comprar productos
estadounidenses hechos en eeuu para
crear trabajos en eeuu y así es como se
supone que debe ser y así será en esta
administración
lo he dejado claro a todos los miembros
de mi gabinete la capacidad de dar
extensiones ha sido demasiado limitada
sobre los productos estadounidenses
ahora al sé que algunos de ustedes en
casa se estarán preguntando si estos
trabajos son para ustedes
y tantos de ustedes tantos de las
personas con las cuales crecí se
quedaron atrás fueron olvidadas
en una economía que cambia tan
rápidamente esto da mucho miedo quiero
hablar directamente a ustedes porque si
lo pensamos
eso es lo que le preocupa a la gente
puedo yo encajar en expertos
independientes estiman que el trabajo
estadounidense
le agrega a crecimiento millones al
crecimiento de este país esto es un
programa de ocho años son trabajos bien
pagos que no pueden ser llevados a otro
lado cerca de 90 por ciento del trabajo
infrestructura creado en eeuu no
requiere un grado escolar 75% no
requiere ningún tipo de estudio este
plan es una este plan tiene la intención
de construir a eeuu reconstruir eeuu
desde la clase trabajadora de eso se
trata
y de este plan reconoce algo que siempre
he dicho en esta cámara y en la otra
hay gente que no construyó este país la
clase media con este país y los
sindicatos construyeron la clase media
por eso es que le pido al congreso
que apruebe el acta pro act y la envía a
mi escritorio para poder respaldar el
derecho a crear sindicatos
y por cierto
cuando lo pensamos en las cosas que hay
en mi escritorio
levantemos el salario mínimo a 15
dólares
nadie
[Aplausos]
nadie que trabaja 40 horas a la semana
madre que trabaja 40 horas a la semana
debería vivir por debajo de la línea de
pobreza debemos asegurar mayor equidad y
mayor oportunidades para mujeres
mientras lo hacemos
hagamos que esta acta de la paga igual
llegue a mi escritorio ha pasado mucho
tiempo y se preguntan cuánto es mucho
tiempo miren hacia atrás
finalmente
los trabajos de unidenses
tienen el mayor crecimiento en
investigación y desarrollo no dedicada a
la defensa hemos visto gran cambio
tecnológico muchos saben más de eso que
yo pero vemos más cambio tecnológico en
los próximos lo veremos en los próximos
diez años que en los últimos 50 años así
de rápido miremos una inteligencia
artificial hay muchas más cosas que
están cambiando y estamos quedándonos
atrás en la competencia con el resto del
mundo hace décadas solíamos invertir 2
por ciento de nuestro producto interno
bruto en eeuu 2% en investigación y
desarrollo y hoy
si el secretario es menos que 1%
china y otros países están acercándose
rápidamente tenemos que desarrollar y
dominar los productos y las tecnologías
del futuro baterías avanzadas la
biotecnología chips de computadora
energía limpia zecharia defensa puede
decirles y también saben muchos lo que
el departamento de defensa tiene una
agencia llamada tar para la agencia
de investigación avanza de proyectos de
defensa la gente que la estableció antes
de que yo llegara acá pasó hace mucho
tiempo la estableció para desarrollar
desarrollos tecnológicos que mejoren
nuestra seguridad ese es su único
trabajo y es una agencia semi separada
de ese departamento de defensa
ha llevado al descubrimiento del
internet de la tecnología gps y de
muchas otras más que han mejorado
nuestra seguridad el instituto nacional
de salud creo yo debería crear una
agencia un proyecto de investigación
avanzadas y similar para la salud
[Aplausos]
y esto es lo que vamos a hacer tenemos
un propósito único de desarrollar
tecnologías para prevenir detectar y
tratar enfermedades como el alzheimer la
diabetes y el cáncer
nunca olvidaré cuando probamos
la propuesta del cáncer como en mi
último año como vicepresidente cerca de
9 mil millones de dólares llegando al
instituto de salud es un privilegio
personal para mí me acuerdo que me
mencionó esto y después mencionó el
nombre de mi hijo mi hijo que falleció y
significó mucho para mí pero también
para muchos de nosotros hemos visto
y familiares cercanos y amados morir de
cáncer no puedo pensar en una mejor
inversión
no me puedo imaginar nada que sea más
bipartidista acabemos el cáncer como lo
conocemos está en nuestras manos está en
nuestro alcance hacerlo
[Aplausos]
las inversiones en trabajo de
infraestructura como las que estamos
discutiendo han tenido aporta respaldo
bipartidista el último en el pasado la
vicepresidenta y yo nos encontramos
frecuentemente en la oficina oval y
discutimos esos trabajos contemos con
republicanos y demócratas aplaudo a los
senadores que han puesto su propia
propuesta
vamos a trabajar quiero trazar frente al
congreso mi plan
antes de llegar a las discusiones más
profundas quisiera reunirme con aquellos
que tengan ideas y que sean diferentes
para pensarlo mejor yo recibo estas
ideas pero el resto del mundo no está
esperando por nosotros solamente quiero
dejarlo claro desde mi perspectiva hacer
nada no es una opción
miren
no podemos ocuparnos en competir el uno
con el otro y olvidar la competencia que
tenemos con el resto del mundo para
ganarnos este siglo 21 el sectario
blinken puede decirles he pasado mucho
tiempo con el presidente chino
he viajado 1.700 millas 17.000 millones
han pasado más de 24 horas en
discusiones privadas con él
cuando me llamó a felicitarme tuvimos
una discusión de dos horas
él es una persona que se esfuerza mucho
para que china sea la nación más
importante del mundo él y otros
otros autócratas piensan que la
democracia no puede competir en ese
siglo 21
con las autocracias porque toma mucho
tiempo hacer consenso
para ganar esa competencia por el futuro
en mi perspectiva también debemos hacer
una inversión generacional en nuestras
familias y en nuestros hijos por eso es
que he presentado
el plan de familias estadounidenses hoy
que se dirige a cuatro de los desafíos
más importantes que enfrentan las
familias estadounidenses
el primero es acceso a la buena
educación
nación y la educación universal en el
siglo pasado nos convirtió en la nación
más educada más preparada en el mundo es
lo que yo creo lo más importante que nos
impulsó a donde llegamos en el siglo 20
pero el mundo ya nos ha alcanzado está
alcanzando nos ellos no están esperando
diré entre paréntesis que si nos
estuviéramos sentando hablando con un
comité bipartidista vamos a decidir qué
hacer en términos de que el gobierno
pueda dar educación gratuita imagino que
si pensáramos como pensamos en el siglo
20 que 12 años serán suficiente para el
siglo 20 yo la verdad es que lo dudo 12
años no es suficientemente no es
suficiente tiempo para competir con el
resto del mundo por eso es que en mi
plan familia estadounidense garantía es
a 4 años adicionales de educación para
eeuu para cualquier estadounidense para
empezar lo más corto posible las grandes
universidades de país han hecho estudios
los últimos 10 años y esto muestra que
agregar dos años de preescolar gratuita
de alta calidad para cada niño de tres o
cuatro años sin importar de dónde vengan
los pone la posición de poder competir
en todos estos 12 años e incrementa
exponencialmente su prospecto de graduar
y de seguir estudiando más allá de la
graduación la investigación muestra que
cuando un niño va a la escuela no
solamente a las guarderías
tienen una mayor posibilidad de
graduarse del colegio y pasar a la
universidad o incluso algo cualquier
cosa después de la universidad cuando
uno agrega dos años de estudio gratuito
comunitario uno empieza a cambiar las
dinámicas
y nosotros podemos hacer eso
[Aplausos]
e incrementar las becas para los
cubrimientos en las universidades
étnicas y de minorías las razones que
ellos no tienen los respaldos hay gente
que es capaz de aprender de
ciberseguridad y gente que es capaz de
aprender de metalurgia cualquier cosa
que está sucediendo para estos trabajos
del futuro
es una profesora del chiste
universidad comunitaria y ahora es la
primera dama y sigue enseñando y ha
dicho
ha dicho
lo escuché una vez le escuché mil veces
yo cualquier país que eduque mejor que
nosotros va a competir más que nosotros
estará muy comprometida en el liderazgo
de ese esfuerzo y muchas gracias yo la
segunda cosa que necesitamos las
familias el plan familiar eeuu dará
acceso a cuidado infantil accesible
y garantizamos
cuando lo propuse en esta legislación
garantizaremos que las familias de bajos
ingresos no paguen más del 7 por ciento
de su ingreso para atención infantil
para niños menores de 5 años las
familias más trabajadoras no tendrán que
gastar un centavo
eeuu a 12 familias de ellis 12 semanas
de licencia familiar
[Aplausos]
somos uno de los pocos países
industrializados del mundo
nadie debería elegir entre un trabajo y
un salario o de cuidar y cuidarse a sí
mismo a su esposo un hijo y cuarto el
plan de familias estadounidense pone
directamente en el dinero de millones
estadounidenses
en el bolsillo a miles de unidades
dinero en marzo expandiremos el crédito
fiscal para cada niño en la familia
hasta tres mil dólares por niño si
tienen primero de seis años de edad los
que son más de seis años de edad y 3600
dólares para niños que tenga más de seis
años
para familias de dos hijos son 72 mil
dólares más para cuidar a sus familias y
esto ayudará a más de 65 millones de
niños le ayudará
disminuir la pobreza infantil en la
mitad y nosotros podemos pagarlo
en
hicimos eso en la última parte de esa
legislación pero podemos extender este
crédito al menos hasta el final de 2025
[Aplausos]
con los premium de la salud
estadounidenses para 9 millones que
tienen esta cobertura a través del aforo
de walker aquí yo sé que eso puede ser
popular de este lado
pero hagamos que esta provisión sea
permanente para que los premium no
vuelvan incrementar su precio
en adición con el plan de las familias
trabajaré con él con eso para dirigirme
a otras prioridades críticas de este año
para las familias estadounidenses el
acta de salud ha sido una línea de vida
para ellos estadounidenses ha protegido
a la gente con condiciones preexistentes
ha ayudado a las mujeres y su remate de
salud y la pandemia ha demostrado lo
mucho que se necesitan bajemos los
deducibles de las familias que trabajan
que están incluidas en esta forma volver
aquí y bajemos el costo de las drogas de
prescripción
[Aplausos]
sabemos cómo hacer esto
el último presidente tenía ese como
objetivo y todos sabemos lo caro que fue
lo caro que es tener drogas en eeuu
pagamos los precios más altos de
cualquier país del mundo aquí en eeuu
tres veces más con la misma droga
respecto de lo que pasa en otros países
y tenemos que cambiar eso y podemos
hemos hablado de esto por muchos años
incluso los que yo estuve aquí en este
cuerpo del congreso tenemos la medicare
el poder de salvar a millones de
personas negociando los precios de las
drogas de prescripción
por cierto
no solamente ayudar a las personas en
medicare todo de los medicamentos de
precisión sirven para todo si el dinero
que ahorraremos billones miles de
millones dólares pueden fortalecer el
acta de salud y expandir la cobertura de
medicare y sus beneficios sin causarle
más dinero a los contribuyentes está en
nuestras manos hacerlo y podemos hacerlo
ahora
[Aplausos]
hemos hablado de esto demasiado tiempo
demócratas y republicanos logremos lo
este año es una premisa muy simple la
salud debe ser un derecho no un
privilegio en eeuu
así que
como pagar por este programa de familias
estadounidenses se ha dejado claro que
podemos hacerlo sin incrementar el
déficit empecemos con lo que no haré no
impondré en ningún incremento fiscal en
personas que hagan más de cuatrocientos
mil dólares pero es momento de que los
eeuu corporativos 1% que empiecen a
pagar la parte junto al solo lo justo
a veces tengo discusiones con mis amigos
del partido demócrata creo que
deberíamos poder convertirnos en
millonarios originarios pero paguemos la
parte justa estudios recientes muestran
que 55 de las naciones más grandes las
corporación del país pagaron cero
impuestos federales el año anterior
estas 55 corporaciones hicieron una
ganancia de 40 mil millones de dólares
pérez gracias son muchas compañías que
también evaden impuestos con paraísos
fiscales como bermudas suiza y se
benefician de vacíos legales y
deducciones
sacar trabajos fuera del país y eso no
es lo correcto vamos a reformar los
impuestos corporativos para que paguen
la parte justa y ayuden a pagar las
inversiones
públicas de los cuales se beneficiarán
sus negocios
[Aplausos]
vamos a construir más trabajo no
solamente riqueza vamos a tomar la parte
alta de los contribuyentes el 1 por
ciento de estadounidenses más grandes
ellos que hacen más de 400 mil dólares
al año a devolverlo cuando york sobre
bush era presidente cuando empezó 39
puntos 6% así era cuando george w
era presidente vamos a acabar con los
vacíos legales que permite a los
estadounidenses que ganan más de bueno
miles de millones de dólares al año sí
que paguen una tasa fiscal más baja
sobre las ganancias de capital de
aquellos que reciben salarios vamos a
afectar 3
decimos de un porcentaje del 12 por
ciento
[Música]
y también vamos a buscar a los
millonarios y billonarios que evade
impuestos se estima que son miles de
millones de dólares son los saques de
pensamiento de la derecha de la
izquierda del centro no estoy buscando
castigar a nadie pero no voy a agregar
cargas fiscales adicionales a la clase
media de este país ya están pagando
suficiente yo creo que lo que yo
propongo es justo y es fiscalmente
responsable y hay que incrementar el
ingreso dinero para poder pagar estos
planes mejorar nuestra nuestra
estructura financiera como país
escuchaba alguien decir que no
pregúnteles a quien quieren incrementar
los impuestos y a quién quieren cortar
los impuestos a las personas que se
oponen a este plan miren el corte fiscal
de 2017 recuérdenlo se suponía que debía
pagarse a sí mismo así fue como nos lo
vendieron y generar un gran crecimiento
económico en vez de eso agregó 2
billones de dólares al déficit fue un
gran un gran golpe pero para eeuu en vez
de utilizar este dinero que se ahorraron
solamente metieron mucho de sus dineros
a los presidentes
la brecha entre presidentes y empleados
es una edad más grande de la historia
los hijos hacen 320 veces el salario del
trabajador normal de una corporación y
eso solía ser por debajo del 100% la
pandemia solamente ha empeorado esta
situación 20 millones ado unidenses
perdieron su trabajo en la pandemia
gente de clase media y a la vez son más
o menos 600 millonarios estadounidenses
vieron su valor neto crecer en mil
millones de dólares 630 personas
incrementaron su riqueza por más de 1000
millones de dólares en esta pandemia
muy linda
valen más de cuatro mil millones de
dólares
señores estadounidenses por favor la
economía la economía tricolor nunca ha
funcionado es momento de que empecemos a
construir la economía desde abajo y
desde el medio
hay un gran consenso entre economistas
de derecha izquierda y centros están de
acuerdo con que lo que yo propongo va a
crear millones de trabajos y un
crecimiento económico histórico esa es
una de las mejores inversiones que
podemos hacer como nación de mayor valor
frecuentemente digo que nuestra mayor
fortaleza es el poder de nuestro ejemplo
no solamente el ejemplo de nuestro poder
en mi conversación con líderes mundiales
se ha hablado ya ha hablado con 40
he dejado claro el dejado claro que eeuu
está de vuelta y saben qué dicen los
comentarios que oigo de ellos dicen que
vemos que eeuu está de vuelta pero por
cuánto tiempo o por cuánto tiempo
compañeros estadounidenses tenemos que
mostrar tenemos que mostrar no solamente
que estamos de vuelta sino que estamos
de vuelta para quedarnos y que no nos
vamos a ir solos
vamos a hacerlo liderando a nuestros
aliados y con nuestros aliados ninguna
nación puede lidiar con todas las crisis
de nuestra era del terrorismo la
proliferación nuclear la migración
masiva lección de seguridad el cambio
climático tanto como lo que estamos
experimentando ahora en pandemia no hay
ningún muro lo suficientemente alto para
mantener un virus afuera nuestro propio
suministro de vacuna a medida que crece
para enfrentar nuestras necesidades y
las necesidades que estamos enfrentando
se convertirá en un arsenal de vacunas
para otros países así como eeuu es un
arsenal de la democracia para el mundo y
una influencia consecuente para el mundo
cada estadounidense tendrá acceso cada
estadounidense tendrá acceso
tendrá completa cobertura
19 con estas vacunas miren con el cambio
climático no es sólo nuestra lucha es la
lucha de todos los estados unidos tienen
la mitad de las emisiones de carbono del
mundo
el mundo tiene 85% por eso es que tuve
mi compromiso de mantenerme en el
acuerdo de parís porque si lo hacemos
todo de manera perfecta
no solamente importará mantuve mi
compromiso
con eeuu y con todas las economías del
mundo china rusia india la unión europea
dije que lo haría en mis primeros 100
días
quiero ser muy claro al respecto
tuve tiempo para ver para que el mundo
viera que hay un consenso que estamos en
un punto de inflexión de la historia el
consenso es de actuar si actuamos para
salvar el planeta crearemos millones de
trabajos y crecimiento económico y
oportunidades y levantaremos el estándar
de vida para todo el mundo si seguro que
si hay gente de edad no hay mucho tiempo
virtualmente todas las naciones dijeron
eso incluso las que estaban haciendo la
parte justa las inversiones que propongo
hoy también generan avance en política
extranjera y podría beneficiar a la
clase media del mundo es asegurar de que
cada nación esté con las mismas reglas
de la economía global incluyendo chira
me discusiones mis discusiones con el
presidente y yo le dije que recibimos
bien la competencia no estamos buscando
el conflicto
pero he dejado bien claro que
defenderemos los intereses de eeuu en
todas las negociaciones eeuu
e interpretar entre el comercio injusto
y subsidios injustos que vengan de
compañías del estado del robo e
intelectual de propiedad intelectual
también le dije el presidente chino que
mantendremos una presencia militar
fuerte en el indo pacífico así como lo
hacemos con la otan y con europa no para
empezar un conflicto sino para
prevenirlo
[Aplausos]
le dije lo que le dije a muchos líderes
mundiales que eeuu no se retirará de sus
compromisos esos compromisos con los
derechos fundamentales con la libertad
con estas alianzas les resalte que
ningún presidente estadounidense
responsable podría mantenerse callado
cuando los derechos básicos humanos
están siendo violados un presidente
estadounidense tiene que representar la
esencia de lo que nuestro país defiende
eeuu es una idea la idea más única en la
historia está fuimos creados todos
nosotros iguales esto es lo que somos we
can' y no podemos abandonar ese
principio de hecho podemos decir que no
estamos lidiando con esto respecto de
rusia sé que le preocupa a muchos de
ustedes pero deje bastante claro que no
vamos a buscar un escalamiento
pero sus acciones tendrán
consecuencias estos resultados en cierto
es respondido directamente y
proporcionalmente la interferencia rusa
para estas elecciones a los ciberataques
a nuestros negocios y a nuestro gobierno
ellos hicieron estas dos cosas y les
dije que respondería mos y lo hemos
hecho pero también podemos cooperar
cuando está en intereses mutuos yo lo
hicimos cuando extendimos el tratado de
nuclear y estamos trabajando en el
cambio climático pero él entiende que
nosotros responderemos en iraní sobre
irán y corea del norte los programas
nucleares presentan grandes amenazas a
la seguridad estadounidense a la
seguridad del mundo estaremos trabajando
de cerca con nuestros aliados para
dirigirnos a las amenazas que ambos
países nos presentan a través de la
diplomacia tanto como también queremos
acabar la guerra interminable en
organizar
[Aplausos]
sin hipérbole si tenemos la mayor fuerza
de combate de todo el mundo soy el
primer presidente en 40 años que sabe lo
que es tener un hijo que vive en una
zona de guerra evitaremos
tenemos hombres de servicios que están
trabajando en afganistán en gente que ni
siquiera había nacido en el 9/11 la
guerra en afganistán como lo recordamos
en los debates no se suponía que debía
ser multigeneracional la reconstrucción
de esa nación fuimos a afganistán para
sacar a los terroristas a los que nos
atacaron en el 9/11
dijimos que vamos a seguir a osama bin
laden hasta las puertas del infierno
llevamos justicia a bin laden y acabamos
con la amenaza terrorista de al-qaeda en
afganistán y después de 20 años de valor
de sacrificio ya es momento de que estas
tropas regresen a casa
miren
incluso aunque mantenemos la capacidad
de acabar los peligros para nuestra para
nuestro país no cometamos ningún error
aquí en 20 años el terrorismo ya ha
hecho metástasis las amenazas han
evolucionado mucho más que lo que vimos
en organizar los que están en los
comités de inteligencia en los comités
de formulación en los de comités de
defensas lo saben bien tenemos que
seguir siendo vigilantes ante las
amenazas hacia eeuu de donde sea que
vengan al que está en yemen siria
somalia otros sitios de áfrica el medio
oriente mucho más allá y no podemos
ignorar lo que nuestras agencias de
inteligencia han determinado que es la
peor amenaza a este país hoy el
terrorismo y supremacismo blanco no
podemos ignorar eso compañeros
estadounidenses miren
tenemos que reunirnos para sanar el alma
de esa nación
paso a paso casi un año después de la
muerte de su padre hablé con la hija de
george floyd me arrodillé hablé con ella
porque es muy pequeña todavía aquí para
poder verla a los ojos ella me miró y
dijo mi papá cambió el mundo
bueno después de la convicción de
después de el juicio del asesino ellos
prohibimos lo correcto lo correcta que
estaba si tenemos el coraje de actuar
desde el congreso todo hemos visto cómo
funciona la justicia sobre los cuellos
de los afroestadounidenses esta es la
oportunidad de lograr un progreso real
la gran mayoría de hombres y mujeres que
utilizan el uniforme de la placa sirven
a las comunidades honradamente yo los
conozco y sé que quieren
[Aplausos]
yo sé
que quieren ayudarme en ese momento
también señores estadounidenses tenemos
que reunirnos y reconciliarnos para
conseguir la confianza entre las fuerzas
de seguridad y las personas en las que
sirven es acabar el racismo sistemático
en la justicia y la policía crear una
reforma policial que ya ha pasado en la
cámara en nombre ellos dicen que los
republicanos tiene sus propias ideas y
hemos tenido unas ellos han tenido unas
conversaciones productivas con
demócratas en el senado tenemos que
trabajar juntos para llegar a un
consenso pero logremos lo el próximo mes
en el primer aniversario de la muerte de
georg floyd
el país respalda esta reforma y el
congreso debería actuar debería actuar
ya tenemos una oportunidad gigante de
romper el arco del universo mural hacia
la justicia verdadera y con los planes
que he trazado hoy tenemos una
oportunidad real de acabar con el
racismo sistémico que tiene plagado eeuu
las vidas estadounidenses de otras
maneras la posibilidad de vivir en una
equidad real buenos trabajos buenas
escuelas acceso a la vivienda agua
limpia aire limpio poder generar riqueza
y pasarlo de generaciones posteriores
porque hay acceso haga la compra de
casas oportunidades reales de las vidas
desde hoy estadounidenses negros latinos
nativos asiáticos miren también quiero
agradecerle al senado de eeuu por votar
94 a 1 para pasar el acta de crímenes de
odio kobe para proteger a los asiáticos
estadounidenses el accidente pacífico
actuamos de manera decisiva
[Aplausos]
vimos en televisión cómo funcionan estos
odiosos crímenes raciales lo vimos el
año pasado y ya lo hemos visto por mucho
tiempo le pedí a la cámara le pido a la
cámara que haga lo mismo que viene
legislación de mi escritorio al que yo
firmaré con mucho gusto también espero
que el congreso lleve a mi mesa el acta
de igualdad para proteger a los
estadounidenses el egb tipo
[Aplausos]
a todas las personas de esta comunidad
que están viendo los desde casas a la
gente joven son muy valientes sepan que
el presidente está con ustedes por favor
autorizamos el acta contra la violencia
hacia la mujer ya es una deuda muy
grande
[Aplausos]
hace 27 años lo escribí que es el
utilizar cerrará el vacío legal
que impedirá que los abusivos tengan
armas como personas abusivas no pueden
tener armas hay que cerrar ese vacío
legal que existe ahora se estima
que 50 mujeres son asesinadas por una
pareja íntima cada mes en eeuu al menos
50 meses aprobemos esta ley salvemos
vidas
y sé que no necesito decir esto pero la
violencia armada se ha convertido una
epidemia de eeuu la bandera de la casa
blanca todavía está
a media asta por las víctimas de georgia
en colorado el fin de semana entre estos
dos eventos
y 250 estadounidenses fueron asesinados
en las calles de eeuu cientos cincuenta
asesinados
yo sé lo difícil que es lograr un
progreso en este tema en los noventas
pasamos la ley para revisiones
universales un veto a las armas de
asalto y los proveedores de muchas balas
y vencimos a la asociación nacional del
rifle la violencia armada declinó
revisen los reportes de estos diez años
pero al inicio de los 2000
esta ley expiró hemos visto
derramamiento diario de sangre no voy a
decir que no vamos a dejar de beber de
realmente de sangre pero hace dos más de
dos semanas el rose garden rodeado de la
gente más valiente que conozco gente que
sobrevivió a la violencia armada y que
tiene familiares que murieron tras las
acciones que está tomando el
departamento de justicia para enfrentar
esta epidemia una de ellas es vetar
estas armas fantasma son armas caseras
construidas con un kit que incluye
instrucciones sobre cómo terminar estas
armas son partes que no tienen números
seriales así que llegan a escenas del
crimen y no pueden ser rastreadas los
compradores de estos kits fantasma no
deben pasar ningún tipo de registro de
antecedentes que cualquier persona desde
un criminal o terrorista puede comprar
este kit y en 30 minutos tener un arma
letal pero eso no puede ser más haré
todo lo posible mi poder para proteger
al cual estadounidense de esta epidemia
de la violencia armada pero es momento
de que el congreso actúe también
miren
no quiero entrar en confrontación pero
necesitamos que los republicanos se unan
a la mayoría demócrata para cerrar estos
vacíos legales y requerir la revisión de
antecedentes para comprar armas
hicimos un veto sobre armas de asalto y
proveedores de alta capacidad no me
digan que eso no se puede hacer lo
hicimos antes y funcionó hablemos
hablamos con los propietarios de armas
responsables no hay justificación para
tener tantas balas en un arma
acaso los venados utilizan que hay mucha
gente hoy que puede comprar armas y no
debería poder comprarlas este tipo de
reformas tiene un importante respaldo
del pueblo estadounidense incluyendo
muchos propietarios de armas
el país respalda esa reforma el congreso
debe actuar no debería haber un tema de
rojos o azules
ninguna enmienda a la constitución es
absoluta
no se puede gritar fuego desde un teatro
lleno desde el principio hay armas que
no deberían tener que no debería estar
en manos de ningún estadounidense
cierta gente no debería tener estas
armas nunca no estamos cambiando la
constitución
estamos siendo razonables creo que esto
no es un tema demócrata o republicano
sino estadounidense esto es otra cosa
que podemos hacer la migración siempre
ha sido central para eeuu us terminemos
nuestro veto a la migración por más de
30 años la gente ha hablado de la
reforma a la migración y no hemos hecho
nada al respecto el momento de
arreglarlo el primer día en presidencia
mantuve mi compromiso establecido un
comité para reconstruir la migración si
creen que necesitamos proteger la
frontera ciertamente podemos aprobarla
porque hay como un metal de tecnología
si creen un camino a la ciudadanía para
serlo para que 11 millones de personas
indocumentadas una gran mayoría
se dejan pasar su visa apruebe lo he
hecho quiere resolver un problema
enviado un acta para que la revisen bien
todos tenemos que entender el problema
raíz de por qué la gente huye de sus
países particularmente desde guatemala
honduras y el salvador a nuestra
frontera sur
la violencia de corrupción las pandillas
la inestabilidad política los huracanes
terremotos desastres naturales cuando
fui presidente cuando fui vicepresidente
el presidente me pidió que me enfocará
en estas raíces de la migración y pipo
para ayudar a la gente de quedarse en
sus propios países en vez de verse
forzados a irse el plan estaba
funcionando para la última
administración decidió que no valía la
pena
estoy restaurando el programa 'el debido
a la vicepresidenta ya luís que lidere
este esfuerzo diplomático para
encargarse de ellos tengo una confianza
absoluta en que ella lo logrará
y miren
si no les gusta mi plan
al menos aprueben lo que ya hemos
acordado el congreso debe aportar debe
aprobar legislación este año para
proteger a los trimmers a la gente joven
que solamente han conocido a eeuu como
su hogar
y además
protección permanente para los
inmigrantes que están aquí en un estatus
de protección temporal que llegaron de
países
violentos que han soportado muchos
desastres naturales así como un camino a
la ciudadanía para que los trabajadores
puedan poner más comida en sus mesas
y los migrantes han hecho mucho por eeuu
durante esta pandemia y durante toda
nuestra historia el país respalda a la
reforma la migración y debemos actuar
discutamos los debatamos lo actuemos y
si realmente queremos restaurar lo
restaurar el alma de eeuu debemos
proteger el derecho sagrado al voto para
la mayoría de personas
la mayoría de personas que votó en la
elección presidencial anterior que en
cualquier votación de este país en la
peor pandemia esto debe ser celebrado en
vez de ser atacado el congreso debería
aprobar hr1 y el acta de voto de ellos
louis y mandarla a mi escritorio de
inmediato
el país la respalda el congreso debería
actuar ahora
[Aplausos]
reunidos aquí hoy pensamos en las
imágenes de la multitud que de sacro
nuestra democracia todos pensamos en eso
está vivido en esa mente y vidas en
riesgo muchas de sus vidas se perdieron
vidas hubo un gran coraje la
insurrección fue una crisis existencial
y una prueba de si nuestra democracia
podía sobrevivir y lo hizo pero la lucha
aún no se ha acabado la pregunta sobre
si la democracia pueden persistir es
antigua y también es urgente tanto como
nuestra república sigue siendo vital hoy
esta pregunta puede nuestra democracia
responder a sus promesas nosotros todos
viviendo vidas de dignidad iguales ante
la ley por respeto a las posibilidades
puede nuestra democracia entregar pues
responder a las necesidades apremiantes
de nuestra nación
resolver los miedos el odio que nos
separan los adversarios de eeuu los
autócratas del mundo están haciendo
apuestas porque no podemos
y les aseguro que ellos creen que no
podemos creen que estamos muy divididos
enojados airados miren ellos creen que
esa multitud que atacó el capitolio que
es el ocaso de nuestra democracia y
están equivocados ustedes lo saben yo lo
sé pero tenemos que probar que se
equivocan tenemos que probar que la boca
este todavía funciona que el gobierno
funciona y que podemos responderle a
nuestro pueblo en los primeros nosotros
y el día juntos he trabajado para
resonar la fe la democracia hemos
vacunado a la nación
hemos creado cientos de miles de
trabajos nuevos hemos entregado
resultados reales a la gente que pueden
ver y sentir en sus propias vidas
abriendo puertas de oportunidades
garantizando justicia equidad esa es la
esencia de eeuu esa es la democracia en
acción nuestra constitución
abre con estas palabras nosotros el
pueblo hay que recordar que nosotros el
pueblo somos el gobierno ustedes y yo no
una fuerza en el capitolio de instante
no una fuerza poderosa que no
controlamos somos nosotros
nosotros el pueblo en otra era nuestra
democracia fue puesta bajo prueba frank
dijo que era eeuu todos hacemos nuestro
trabajo nuestra parte y eso es todo lo
que le estoy pidiendo a ustedes que
hagamos nuestra parte todos nosotros
si hacemos eso enfrentaremos los
desafíos de nuestra era al demostrar que
esta democracia es duradera y es fuerte
los autócratas no vencerán no ganarán el
futuro nosotros lo haremos y eeuu hará
el futuro le pertenece a eeuu
aquí estoy frente a ustedes en una hora
importante de la democracia de la vida
restauración y puedo decir con absoluta
confianza que nunca he tenido mayor
confianza o mayor optimismo sobre eeuu
porque sea el presidente sino por lo que
está sucediendo con el pueblo
estadounidense wilster hemos mirado
hacia el abismo de la insurrección y de
la autocracia la pandemia del dolor
nosotros el pueblo no nos movimos ni
miramos otro lado
en el momento en que los adversarios
creían que nos íbamos a desmoronar ya
fracasar nos reunimos bajo la luz bajo
la esperanza convocamos estas nuevas
fortalezas esta nueva resolución para
buscar ganar esta competencia por el
siglo 21 nuestro camino a la unión a un
unión más perfecta más prósperas y mucho
más justa
como un solo pueblo una sola nación y un
solo estados unidos
damas y caballeros le he dicho a todos
los líderes mundiales que nunca ha sido
un mal buen momento para mostrar en
contra de eeuu si este momento no es
diferente somos eeuu
no hay nada que esté más allá de
nuestras capacidades nosotros podemos
hacer lo que sea que queramos hacer si
lo hacemos juntos entonces empecemos a
reunirnos todos me diga a todos y dios
proteja a nuestras tropas muchas gracias
por su paciencia
[Aplausos]